welcome all
um and welcome to my talk um that's
either called chasing a wheel down a
rabbit hole or 10 times smaller docker
images for
data science um
right so i actually have a data global
slide in here that we don't actually
need
so about me um as rubin already said
uh i'm i'm actively involved in the pi
data ecosystem so in the culture of
amsterdam and advisor of panetta global
at work
i'm responsible for training and
educating junior media data scientists
in a bunch of different topics and i
like to do some open source so psychic
lego
is a practice i mean chain with vincent
who was here yesterday um
and time series is something that i
recently started to do
bayesian hierarchical time theories
estimation but that's not why we're here
today
uh we're here today basically because of
this tweet it popped up on my timeline
like a couple of months ago and jason
here asked
if you try how small can you get a
docker container for the paydata stack
with like pandas numpy
sci-fi inference and that's sort of an
interesting question in and of itself
but he asks like how small can it
reasonably get
and it always triggers me because then
i'm also curious about how small can
this get
if you let that reasonable constraint go
and
that led me down a rabbit hole and and
this question intrigued me
so today i'll be sharing my search in
how small can we get
a docker container for the payload stack
and this entire question is kind of
ironic because well whales don't really
fit down in rabbit holes in the first
place
anyway what are we talking about let's
say we have a model training container
right so we have metal blip maybe to to
do some plotting at the end
we use numpy we use pandas we use
scikit-learn
basically all the like the regular pi
data stacks stuff for
training uh training machine learning
models those packages have some
dependencies of the run
so this then becomes our complete
requirements file
that we have for for our docker
container that's the things that we need
in our docker container
and a very basic just straightforward
run-of-the-mill docker file to build an
image based off of these requirements
would look something like this
so we pick our base image python38
we copy in our requirements and we pip
install those and we copy in the rest of
our source code
our application source code and then we
install our package
we run some kind of some kind of test to
see if everything works
and and this works fine but if you build
this you
suddenly realize why docker chose the
largest mammal on earth as their mascot
because this image is 1.7 gigabytes
and for a very simple docker container
um with some python stuff
that's actually quite insane so jason's
question was very relevant like
we we should probably think about how we
can make these smaller
and where do we start and the thing i
always want to start with is like
the main step one is always to think
about what your application needs
do we actually understand what our app
needs to run do we know what third party
tools it needs what third party details
it doesn't need
what kind of development libraries are
needed and that might get installed
maybe but maybe we don't need them
um all those kinds of things because for
example there was this copy.dot
which just copies the entire working
directory
of our docker uh like of our project
into the docker image
i'm not sure about you but like a
typical project i do at a client
has a folder structure that looks
something like this we have a git folder
where our entire git history is in we
have an ide folder that contains
random settings for our development
environment maybe we have some local
data
maybe we have some locally trained
models but more importantly
we have a virtual envin there that has
all our dependencies
so if we do a copy. all that stuff gets
copied
into the container as well whereas we
well we're going to install new
dependencies in the container so we
definitely don't want
our local virtualenv in there
so let's just start with not copying
those kinds of things in
and the tool for that sorry is a docker
ignore file
and the docker ignore file works very
similarly as a git ignore file
in that it basically gives a list of
things that you don't want to be copied
in the container
even if you do a copy dot dot so
what you see here for example the dot
git folder we don't need that in our
container
we don't need the virtual env in our
container we don't need data models
notebooks
um maybe we also don't need tests in our
container right that's a bit of a
personal preference but some people say
no for production use i don't need my
tests to actually be in there
um and that can save some some some size
as well so when we add this docker
ignore file to the root
of our project structure and we rebuilt
it
we see that indeed this already slims
down
our docker image size quite a bit 1.7
gigs down to 1.3
basically we shouldn't ignore the docker
ignore
but then right what is the next step
probably
we need to figure out where most of the
size
of our docker image actually comes from
right what is making our docker image
this big
and to do that we can run a command
called docker history
and we can run docker history on an
image name and it will list
basically per layer in that image
what it was created by and what the size
is
so when we look at this we see um
so 360 megabytes that came from our pip
install requirements
um the rest is kind of small except for
like the base image the from python 3.8
which adds almost a gigabyte
and that brings us therefore to step two
which is use a smaller base image
right most of the size of our image now
comes from our base image so that's
probably
what we want to tackle first and a good
reasonable
first step there is to instead of use
python38
use python38-slim and
the image is based on debian as well
just like python38
python38 is based on deviant but it uses
the slim version of db
it doesn't actually change anything
about the python installation
on the image it just makes sure that
there are less like
commonly used packages that are
installed in regular debian
but aren't installed in this debian slim
so they aren't installed in python 38
and the only thing we actually need to
do is add this slim to our first line
and rebuilding this gives a much more
reasonable 489 megabytes
of disk space and that's a huge
difference for not a lot of work
um so i would always recommend use
python 38 slim except if you have a very
good reason not to
but right so the base image of python 3
8 slim is about 180 megabytes
um so that means we have still like 360
megabytes
from other layers right and we already
saw in the docker history command that
that
mostly stemmed from this uh
this pip install requirements.txt
and what we now might want to do is
figure out what are those 350 megabytes
where
like what is in there do we actually
need all of them
and my favorite tool to find out what's
actually
driving up the size of our docker images
is a tool called dive
and dive is a terminal ui
and this terminal ui will basically
allow you to
allow you to look through the layers and
look through the uh
the file system corresponding to those
layers so what i have in the left here
is
um the top left basically here are all
my different layers in my docker file
i can go through them i can see like
what is the what's that id
the hash id of the layer what is the
command that made it
um but i can also see on the right here
like what did it actually
change right so this pip install
requirements file actually
added like 318 megabytes in the root
and 87 megabytes in this user folder
um and if we look at for example what is
in this route
we will find that 72 megabytes are added
by a cache folder
where there is a pip folder and it
basically caches
apparently some http requests
and if you think about it that's not
really needed
because what pip does is when you pip
install something
it indeed caches those packages
somewhere on your disk
so that if you need them in next time
you don't have to re-download them again
but in this docker container we're not
going to reinstall
pip packages so we don't need them cash
then we could probably just get away
with this
and very similarly in this local lib
python38 site packages
this is where we see where our actual
packages are installed
and we could look around here as well
and pro and take a look at like what
are these where are these megabytes
coming from and
for example there's some some
interesting things if you look at the
metal lip toolkits
in the tests folder there is three and a
half megabytes of base images
and probably we don't need those either
in our docker container
and there's also pi cache files which we
probably don't actually need in our
container either and like there's some
kind
some packages have docs in there which
also can have a lot of images and html
files or javascript
that we also don't need to actually run
so the next step that we want to
probably do
is remove all those unneeded
unneeded files
and something that we could try to do
for example is just
run some commands to actually delete
them so after installing our
requirements in the highlighted block
you see that we try to
delete the um the pip cache folder
and we use find to find like text files
markdowns
images all those kinds of things that
we're not going to need and remove them
from the site packages folders as well
and if we don't build this what we
actually find is that it
made our bit image bigger right we went
up from 489 megabytes
to 503 so why didn't this
slim down our image essentially what
happens
is that every statement in a docker file
makes a new layer and each layer can
only add
information and they don't interact with
each other
so the way that the data gets deleted or
the files gets deleted in
next layers in a docker file basically
is that they they mark certain files
with a tombstone
saying act as if this file is deleted
without actually removing the file from
previous layers
so how this looks for our image is that
we take from python 3.8 slim which is
138 13 megabytes
layer and it gets all compressed like
the file system contents get compressed
in a tar
the copy requirements.txt adds a couple
of bytes
because it adds this requirements.txt
and then the contents of the
requirements.txt
get tired as well and we store those as
a separate layer
hip installing them adds this cache
folder and that's the site packages
folder
and all the content will be in another
tar
and then we can run our mrf root cache
pip
afterwards but what we actually see is
that it just marks files for deletion
it doesn't go back and change our
previous layer
tar and the same thing for that big find
statement
and then the actual size of our image is
the combined size of all these different
layer tars so even though we delete
stuff later on
it's still going to be in our image
which brings us to step three
which is use as few layers as possible
what i typically do is i sort of develop
my docker files in separate blocks
but if possible combine them later on
so don't create unneeded files those
kinds of things
what that looks like in for our image is
basically rather than having separate
run statements
we do it all instead one single big line
right so we pip install the requirements
and then on the next line
in the same run statement though we uh
double ampersand
to run the find the big find statement
and delete those
uh we do the same thing for the pi cache
folder and already in the pip install
there's an option that says no cache
there which makes sure that we don't get
this this pip
cache thing
um in this way we once again
shave off quite a bit of data right we
didn't delete anything that was
necessary for
our container to run we just deleted
cached stuff
and and tests and those kinds of things
and this way we're down to 326 megabytes
and now we're starting to get um
starting to get in in more serious
territory of disk space
saving um if you don't want to do this
manually by the way if you don't want
to compress all your statements into a
single run statement
docker recently introduced it introduced
a
squash option when you do a docker build
and then what it basically does is it
creates
one single uh image at the end of
everything every one single layer out of
your image at the end of everything so
it squashes all your layers for you
right so now we're at 325 megabytes
and now we're starting to get again in
the space where our base image is taking
up
a large portion of our of our space of
our size
and if you've talked to people about
making small docker images probably you
will have gotten the recommendation
just use alpine as a base image alpine
linux is indeed
very tiny um and if we look at like the
python 3 8 alpine version
we see that it's literally only five and
a half megabytes
and using alpine you're told will make
your images smaller and it will speed up
your builds
so let's go ahead let's go and try that
when we change our basic docker
file from python38 to python 38 alpine
so we we changed again the first the the
first
line there the from statement and when
we go and try and build that
we run into an issue right we get a
command errored out with exit status one
uh python setup the pi egg info
and if we then scroll through the logs
and compare
the differences between our images like
between the the python three eight and
the python 3 8 alpine
this is what we see so in the top here
we have the build log from
installing metal lip in python 3 8 and
on the bottom here
we have the build log from installing
map voltage and python 3 8 alpine
and what we see is that there's only
like a slight difference and the last
line is different
right because whereas in python 3.8
we're downloading a file called
matplotlib 321
something something many linux.whl
in the 3.8 alpine version
we are downloading
mathfoldlib3.2.1.tarlgz
right and this is the only thing that's
like this is the first thing that's
different and then from here on out
things crash so
so what's going on here it turns out
that there's these things called wheels
and wheels are
are certain distributions of python
packages
and it turns out that the wheels that
there are on pipeei are not compatible
with with alpine so
so what is a wheel and like why doesn't
alpine use them
um there's different ways in which we
can
ship python packages and for most
packages it doesn't really matter but
for a large portion
of the package that we use in data
science it does
because most packages that we use in
data science don't just use python
they're so-called extension packages
which means that they rely on certain
that they rely on c as well which means
that we need a compiler to actually
compile that c
code before we can run it and we
probably have third party c
dependencies that our packages depend on
like
uh like blast dependencies for example
for numpy
that need to be in place before we can
compile against them
so if we get source code we need to
compile it
but if we get a wheel we apparently
don't
because wheels are a binary distribution
format so it's already a build version
of our python package
and because it's pre-built we don't need
to do any compilation steps
for example if we look at pandas there's
two ways in which we can
build an a shippable image a shippable
package out of this
we can run python instead of the pi s
disk on the left left
we can run python set up the pi beatist
wheel on the right
so the sdist on the left stands for a
source distribution
and when we look at the source
distribution what we actually see is
that it's just a big tar
again with all the source code of pandas
in there
so especially in the lips folder for
example you see algos.c and lgos.pxd in
pi
x whereas on the right
in the wheel version those are replaced
with certain shared objects
these dot so files and
that basically means that in our wheel
they are already compiled for us
so when we install a wheel we don't we
don't need those to do those compilation
steps ourselves anymore
and so why are they then incompatible
with
alpine like why doesn't alpine use these
wheels
it turns out that linux has a lot of
different flavors and each flavor can be
slightly different
meaning that compiled stuff on one linux
flavor might not work on
another so what the writers of the wheel
pep
thought of was let's define a standard
subset
of functionalities that we can expect to
work on many different kinds of linux
installations
and that subset is called many linux and
part of that subset is that everything
should be compiled against
a certain standard library version of
the c standard library
namely the glib c implementation
it turns out that alpine doesn't use the
ellipses they use something called
moodle
and it's slightly different um so
if we want to run c extensions python
with c extensions
on alpine they have to be compiled
against muzzle but since that is not
part
of the many linux spec the wheels that
are on pi
pi aren't compiled against muzzle
basically meaning we have to compile
everything ourselves
and to compile things we need to have
certain build dependencies in place
and it turns out that for the packages
that we have the most important ones are
free type dev
and lippy and g-dev which are
dependencies that
matte public needs and open blast dev
for uh numpy and sci-fi and the likes
then g plus plus and multiple
differences more standard dependencies
that we need
in any in any case and
there's another interesting side effect
here that so so these dependencies are
kind of enough to actually install all
of our stuff
but it turns out that if we have
scikit-learn in the requirements of txt
it doesn't work either because um
so i could learn when you run the set of
the pi actually already expects numpy
and scifi to be installed
but what pip install does when it
installs a list of packages
it first runs all the setup.pies and
then goes and installs it
so you get this sort of bootstrap
problem where you need to install numpy
and sci-fi first and then you can only
install
scikit-learn right so we have our build
dependency
into place and and when we build this it
will work
um it does take a bit of time though
building this
image uh the first time took almost an
hour
like 59 minutes and 31 seconds and it
actually
made our build bigger again so
using alpine will speed up your builds
will make your images
smaller is not necessarily true because
in this case we
we obviously see that it's not that
simple
um but there's still some like there's
still probably some leeway that we can
get here right because
what we did was we installed all those
build time dependencies
whereas we don't really need them in
runtime
so probably we should try to remove
those build time dependencies from our
container
and something that you could try to do
um
is just to delete some of the uh the
build ups
after you've installed everything but
we've already seen with like the
delay how the layers work and the
tombstones why this won't
work right so you might be tempted now
to say okay let's put it all in one
single
line like one single layer but with the
build times that we're talking about
here with these hour-long
builds you kind of want this docker
image
caching this layer caching to work
because otherwise speed of iteration is
just going to be absolutely terrible
and thankfully there's a nice feature
that that
that's possible to use here that sort of
gives you the best of both worlds
and those are called multi-stage builds
um
if you have so what you can do in one
docker file
is have two different images
we can have a python 3 8 alpine image as
a builder
and a python 3.8 slim as a runner
and what we can do in the builder image
is make sure that we have all the
dependencies
into place and in the runner image we
just need to copy
the install stuff from the builder image
so we go through the same motions in our
builder but in our runner we just copy
from the builder from the from the
installed packages in the builder
and we only install the runtime
dependencies open blast and free type in
this case
and that brings our size down
significantly again
megabytes and we're not below the
python38 slim yet but
at least it gives us some indication
that we can probably still
continue right they're still merit to
this road
and one of the things that you might ask
yourself now is that why did we still
need open blast and free type
because we could build our own wheels
right and we didn't need open glass and
free type on python 38 slim
so why do we need them on alpine if
we're building wheels anyway
and that's actually true
but something that we need to do
manually though to make that work
is fix our wheels
so when we when we build a wheel with
pip
wheel we just compile everything and put
it in in a wheel file
but there's a tool called audit wheel
which we can use to check
whether our wheel is many linux
compatible
and not only that it actually also is
able to
fix your wheels to make them more many
linux compatible
so if we look for example on an alpine
build version of numpy
and we run audit will show on it it will
tell us that there are external shared
libraries required by the wheel
namely mozul gcc and openblast and
libstd c plus and
what it can now do is when we run
audible repair
it can take those shared dependencies
and actually copy them into our wheels
and when we do this for all our packages
by just finding all the wheel files that
we built and repairing them
and then copying those installed wheels
into our runner image
it turns out that we can do away with
the with the open blast and free type
dependencies in our runner
and then we're already at 288 megabytes
and this is kind of cool because now we
built the python38 slim benchmark
and now it's just a matter of squeezing
out whatever we can still
get and if you've worked with c
or c plus or anything in the past uh you
probably know that if you're compiling
your packages yourself anyway
you might want to try adding some
compiler flags because even though we
can't
partially install python packages
we can ask the c compiler to make the c
dependencies of our python packages as
small as it possibly can
by for example giving it an optimized
disk space flag
or a remove debug information flag
if we tried it on scipy we actually see
that the size of sci-fi goes down from
35 megabytes to 26 megabytes
and there's probably some other flags
that you could play around with but
these were the ones that i found to have
the biggest effect
and adding these to our build steps is
actually quite straightforward we just
have to set
a c flags environment variable before we
run pip wheel
to tell it please optimize for disk
space and remove all these debug
information stuff
and that removes another 50 megabytes so
we're getting we're getting very close
now to to a 10 time
a 10 times size decrease um
so let's dive in once more into our into
our image to see
what is causing this last bit of
this last bit of data so
this is the image that we just talked
about and
if we go to the root folder to the
python38 folder
what we can for example do is still look
at what is
taking up most space in our image
and something that you might see that
wasn't there before is this scifi.lips
folder and that is actually the
libraries that came from this wheel
repairing stuff
and if we open that we see open blast
that takes 30 megabytes
the thing is though that if we open
numpy libs
that we also see lib open blast that
takes 30 megabytes
the file names are the same and actually
when you when you compute the hashes on
them they are also the same
so these files are exactly the same
they're just duplicates in our image
that we don't actually need
so that's sort of the last thing that we
probably want to get rid of
and something that we can quite
straightforwardly do is delete the numpy
version of lib open blast
and make a sim link so this ln s makes a
sim link from
the scipy lib open blast to the numpy
label from that
we can't do this for only liv open blast
we can do this for all these
shared object libraries that we actually
need it
and when we do that we end up at a
docker image of 188 megabytes
and that's actually where i got stuck um
and this is the smallest that i was able
to get this docker file
should you do this though right on the
left we have a 326 megabytes
image that builds in less than five
minutes
and just works whereas on the right we
have a monstrosity
to to do all the things that we
described up until now
it builds in way over an hour um yeah
it's like half the size but still
probably not worth it that said i do
hope that
some of the things in here at least made
you think about how do python packages
actually work and how do they get
installed
and how does that work in our docker
containers and stuff like
removing cache files is easy and we
should probably do that
and stuff like sharing sharing external
dependencies
is maybe less easy but it also is not
very risky and that
part doesn't take that long and we might
actually do want to do that part
so in conclusion when you want to think
about small docker images
think about your applications needs
first and make sure you thoroughly
understand them
this trip learned me a lot about wheels
and how that entire process works
um and i think if you have like try to
get that knowledge and try to use it to
build smaller images
or do something else don't ignore your
docker ignore that's probably the
easiest way to save as much as you can
try to use small base images python38
slim is a great
useful base image and probably should be
the default for
all your all your python docker images
use as few layers as possible and if
possible
remove any build-time dependencies
that's it thanks
yes thank you not dice
so we're a little bit over time so i can
uh only uh
take one question um it's a little bit
related to the end of your
talk where you have some very nice
recommendations what to focus upon
but um what is your opinion a little bit
more from a
data scientist skill set perspective
this is quite heavily
engineering so what what do you expect
of a data scientist that they
at least you know about uh considering
this topic
right that's that's a good question i
think like the
most important one would be your docker
ignore right make sure that you don't
copy models in the
in the images um that you don't need
in in production time uh don't copy data
that you don't
need at production time and then i would
say the second thing would be the
the multi-stage builds because there's
some some nice little tricks that you
can do
with for example running your tests in
the builder
and then not having them in the runner
which like decreases the
the dependencies you need in in runtime
and those kinds of things
and it turned out that that's relatively
straightforward as well
um the rest of the stuff probably not
not super like you might run into these
kinds of things right if you run on very
restricted images from from a company
where
you need to sort of figure out like hey
can i build a wheel of this and can i
deploy that myself um but that's
starting to get more into engineering
new territory definitely
okay cool well thank you very much